what happened to Japan Japanese
Electronics used to be absolutely
everywhere we'd watch movies on Japanese
DVD players and Japanese TVs products
made in Japan were synonymous with high
quality and affordability and its
biggest electronics companies Sony sharp
Hitachi Panasonic Toshiba they were
household names around the world so what
happened the unconditional surrender of
Japan I think people need to be keeping
their eyes on Japan
the jobs have been lost Japan Japan
following World War II Japan was in
Ruins and on the verge of famine the
Catalyst for its miraculous recovery was
actually Another War the Cold War by the
late 1940s and early 1950s battle lines
were quickly being redrawn the United
States and Soviet Union recently allies
became adversaries in the middle of 1953
forces in the north of Korea invaded the
South for a while it looked like they
would successfully capture Seoul the
capital city that was until the United
States got involved on one side stood
North Korean forces and the Soviet Union
on the other the South and the United
States it was the first proxy conflict
of the new Cold War armies met on a
battlefield that just a few years
earlier had been a Japanese Colonial
possession at first the U.S army shipped
supplies all the way from the United
States but this was massively
inefficient so increasingly it turned to
the Japanese economy for Munitions and
other supplies this demand stimulated
Japan's economy reintegrating it with
World Markets while while also providing
the basis for what would become a big
strength in industrial manufacturing
sensing this Japan's prime minister
hayato Akita embarked on a policy of
sustained economic development through
heavy industrialization to achieve this
he harnessed the recently established
Ministry of international trade and
Industry miti miti would become a key
player in Japan's economic development
by coordinating Japan's banking sector
and Industrial manufacturers it oversaw
the emergence of major integrated
conglomerate groups called keretsu it
was influential enough to direct the
kairatsu to focus on priority industries
that were vital for industrialization
like coal mining steel production
chemicals and shipbuilding but miti also
wanted the keretsu to become strong in a
new industry that was becoming
economically and technologically
significant Electronics despite the
devastation of World War II Japan's
early transistor learning efforts were
extensive in 1952 on a trip to the
United States Masaru Ibaka the founder
of a small electronics company called
Tokyo telecommunications Engineering
Corporation learned that at T was about
to start licensing out the transistor to
other companies thereby making it
available for use by other companies and
researchers Abaco was able to persuade
officials at miti to pay the 55 000
licensing fee so that Sony could use the
transistor in its own products that
interaction demonstrated a key feature
of Japan's economic model when they
needed low-cost Capital to fund
investment Business Leaders could go
directly to the government ibako
returned to the United States in search
of ideas from American transistor
manufacturers he decided that the best
early application would be a transistor
radio in August of 1955 his company
released its first radio the tr-55 the
tr-55 was actually the first product
released under the company's new brand
name Sony the TR 50 5 was important but
Sony knew it could improve the
technology that's why before the end of
1957 it had already released the tr-63
the tr-63 had an important advantage
over competitors like the Regency tr1 it
could fit into people's pockets it soon
became the first transistor radio to
sell more than a million units and it
allowed Sony to establish itself in the
world's biggest Market the United States
this was a huge moment for Japan and a
huge payoff for Sony the company had bet
everything on the transistor radio if it
failed the company was doomed but its
success paved the way for other Japanese
electronics companies encouraged by the
sales of the tr-63 Sony's competitors
Toshiba and sharp decided to scale up
their own production of transistor
radios by 1959 there were more than 6
million japanese-made transistor radio
sets in the United States Sony the first
mover Grew From seven employees to 500.
this incredible success showed other
Japanese firms and to miti that they
should invest in transistor production
by 1960 Japanese transistor production
reached parity with the United States it
was just one of the first triumphs of an
epic decade in 1960 prime minister Akita
announced a plan to use tax breaks
infrastructure investment and Export
incentives to double the size of the
country's economy in 10 years he did it
in less than seven the plan didn't just
Succeed In the words of one historian it
enshrined economic growthism as a
national secular religion the Japanese
model became a blueprint for Rapid
economic growth it was being studied
closely in South Korea Taiwan and China
and would provide inspiration for their
own economic Miracles by the late 1960s
Japan's recovery was virtually complete
it had risen From the Ashes of World War
II to the first rank of economic powers
for its government and major companies
it was time to shift from recovery to
dominance Japan's economy wasn't just
booming it was maturing simple products
like textiles and lightning
manufacturing decreased in importance
compared to more complex manufactured
goods such as cars ships and electronics
improved industrial capacity was also
filtering down to Consumers suddenly
every Japanese family needed its three
Treasures a refrigerator a washing
machine and a TV the all-powerful miti
which had spent years protecting
Japanese firms by forcing foreign
companies to license their technology to
Japanese producers at discounted rates
as a condition of doing business in
Japan they were looking for new
opportunities miti set its sights on
semiconductors in 1971 they reorganized
the Japanese computer industry from six
separate companies into three paired
groups this evolved into direct
coordination of r d across the Japanese
semiconductor industry and before long
the vlsi project very large-scale
integrated circuits the LSI brought
together five of Japan's leading
semiconductor companies NEC Toshiba
Hitachi Mitsubishi and Fujitsu
collectively they were often known as
the Sogo denki general electric
companies at the time these were some of
the biggest companies in Japan which
meant they were increasingly influential
overseas Hitachi was one of the world's
largest producers of analog computers
Toshiba controlled 63 subsidiaries and
employed more than a hundred thousand
people Mitsubishi was a massive
conglomerate that extracted natural gas
in the sultanate of Brunei and coal in
Australia and Fujitsu was on the Leading
Edge of computer production in Japan
these were big companies and normally
they were major Rivals but they were
brought together for a common cause to
overcome the lead held by Foreign
competitors mainly U.S companies in
high-tech production the LSI borrowed
from the same Playbook that had already
served Japan so well participants
enjoyed easy access to Capital the
benefits of government-sponsored
research access to engineering talent
and strategies for licensing technology
from foreign suppliers the project also
assigned different parts of the
microfabrication process to r d staff at
the participating companies
interestingly consumer electronics like
the ones that Sony produced were
excluded this was all about industry the
vlsi project started in 1976. by the
time it wrapped up in 1980 it generated
more than a thousand patents on all
parts of the micro fabrication process
it quickly became apparent that it had
helped supercharge Japan's burgeoning
semiconductor industry by 1982 Japanese
semiconductor companies were producing
more Dynamic Random Access Memory chips
or drams than America was and in 1983
they were still spending more money on
new facilities by the middle of the
decade Japan was spending more on R D
and making more semiconductor products
in total than America according to one
report from the time Japanese firms
controlled 90 percent of world
production of 256 kdrams it's almost
impossible to believe just 40 years
earlier Japan's cities and economy were
in ruins now it was consuming more
semiconductors than the United States
and putting them in cars computers and
other high-tech products Japan's
economic model combines several key
features strong government influence
close collaboration between Banks and
manufacturers and outstanding education
system that produced highly skilled
graduates protection from overseas
competitors low wages and a devalued
currency that made its exports more
attractive but there's another important
feature I haven't mentioned yet John
Gibbons was a physicist who spent 15
years at Oak Ridge National Laboratory
and then served a long and distinguished
career in government he had this to say
about another of Japan's key strengths
we gave free doctorates in nuclear
science to their students and brought
them to Oak Ridge but you have to
realize that the Japanese already had
traditional skills and techniques they
are ahead of us in productivity and
Automobiles in steel in robotics they
recruit their managers from the factory
floor we get ours out of law schools
what John was talking about was close
related to Japan's leading education
system but it wasn't quite the same
thing there's an important word in
Japanese mono zukori its literal
translation is production or making of
things it's the Japanese term for
manufacturing but it has a broader
meaning that encompasses technological
progress know-how and desire to innovate
although the term monozukuri wasn't in
use at the time it helps to explain
Japan's centuries of expertise in the
production of fine crafts and Ceramics
and it also helps explain why its
manufacturers in diverse Fields like
shipbuilding car making and electronics
achieved such incredible things so
quickly when we think of the legacies of
Japanese manufacturing it's easy to
think of specific gadgets or cars the
Sony Walkman or the tr-63 transistor
radio the PlayStation the Toyota Corolla
but the greatest Innovations weren't the
products they were the processes you've
heard of lean manufacturing right or
just in time production both were
heavily based on the Toyota production
system a comprehensive management
practice developed by its industrial
Engineers over 25 years following World
War II how about Kaizen the practice of
incremental continuous Improvement
interestingly some of these Concepts
were introduced by American Business
teachers during the period of U.S
occupation in Japan's classrooms and
Factory floors they found fertile ground
these were methods of scaling production
with maximum efficiency and minimum
waste and they're part of why Japanese
manufacturers for a brief period of time
achieved the dominance they did Japan's
rise in semiconductors is part of the
reason why it became the world's second
largest economy but instead of welcoming
Japan's incredible rise as an amazing
success story lots of Americans were
really angry their mood wasn't helped by
aggressive language like this from a
Hitachi sales presentation to their
denver-based staff in 1985. quote 10
percent below competition if they
re-quote bid 10 under again the bidding
stops when Hitachi wins just 40 years
previously Itachi was making weapons
used in World War II now it almost
sounded like it was encouraging its
sales reps to engage in a different kind
of War a trade War many American
complaints were well founded miti
subsidized Japanese semiconductor
companies which enabled them to sell at
artificially low prices in foreign
markets a trade practice known as
dumping by 1985 America's trade deficit
with Japan stood at about 50 billion
dollars but the community and political
leaders didn't always express their
anger in the right ways one notorious
incident occurred when a Toshiba
subsidiary secretly sold the Soviet
Union equipment that made its submarines
quieter and therefore more dangerous to
the U.S Navy in response nine members of
Congress assembled at the U.S Capitol
and smashed a Toshiba Boombox with
sledgehammers the footage was played
over and over in Japan as an example of
American intolerance Japan bashing
resonated with a wide swath of the
American public in the 1980s from car
companies in Detroit to electronics
manufacturers in Silicon Valley American
manufacturing was declining and Japan
was the culprit at least according to
politicians eager to find someone to
blame here's a typical quote from back
then we have to stop showing that white
flag to start running up the American
flag and to turn around fight and make
America number one again in
international Commerce so that American
jobs are filled in this country if we
don't get cracking get serious and get
leadership our kids will be cheated by
us who do you think said this Donald
Trump no it wasn't him although he was
saying this kind of stuff it was Walter
Mondale the Democratic Presidential
nominee in 1984. it wasn't all anger
there was also some admiration of what
Japan had accomplished popular books
with titles like miti and the Japanese
Miracle and Trading Places argued that
America needed to adapt its own
industrial policy to keep up with Japan
in the latter the author Clyde
prestowitz even wrote that the Japanese
Juggernaut cannot stop of its own
volition for Japan has created a kind of
automatic wealth machine perhaps the
first since King Midas a famous American
sociologist Ezra Vogel published a book
called Japan as number one lessons for
America however even as these books were
being published and the boom boxes were
being smashed storm clouds were
gathering on the horizon let's quickly
recap just 40 years on from the utter
Devastation of World War II Japan had
grown into the second largest economy in
the world by pursuing a state-led
industrialization policy that emphasized
close links between manufacturers
suppliers and the banking system and
protection in the form of tariffs and
Technology transfer requirements
Japanese firms grew strong at home and
made inroads in international markets in
1989 32 of the world's top 50 companies
by market capitalization were Japanese
but when you spend years pumping up your
economy you get bubbles and what happens
to Bubbles they burst much has been
written about the causes of Japan's
economic decline the real answer is that
structural long-term weaknesses were
compounded by acute short-term factors
let's begin with the bubble Japan
suffered the indako recession in the
mid-1980s which most economists today
agree was caused by a rapid appreciation
in the value of its currency the Yen the
appreciation of the Yen undercut Japan's
traditional Advantage exports and
capital investment this had been the
cause of so much of its economic
strength between the 1960s and the 1980s
the Japanese government responded by
adopting an expansive fiscal policy at
the same time the bank of Japan which
had declared curbing the Yen's
appreciation and National priority
pursued aggressive monetary easing
eventually after repeated interest rate
cuts the Yen began to drop in value
mission accomplished except not quite
because the bank of Japan's policies
hadn't just engineered a currency
depreciation they had also hugely
inflated asset values at the height of
the market all of the land in Japan a
country the size of California was worth
about 18 trillion dollars or almost four
times the value of all property in the
United States at the time on December 29
1989 Japan's stock market index peaked
at 39
916 points almost five times higher than
at the start of the decade it has never
come close to that Mark since by August
1990 it had plummeted to half its value
other assets also began to to collapse
in desperation the bank of Japan lifted
interest rates in an attempt to take air
out of the bubble but it was too late
starved of capital and suddenly forced
to repay loans with high interest rates
many Japanese companies collapsed but an
asset price crash is only half of the
story of Japan's collapse the other half
of the story is about an inability to
respond to change by the late 1980s and
early 1990s other nations especially
Japan's East Asian neighbors were
gaining ground taiwan's semiconductor
industry led by tsmc began to gain
market share in South Korea new
conglomerates such as Samsung Hyundai LG
and others were contributing to that
country's own economic Miracle helped
Along by lower labor costs and better
targeted government support for business
r d and investment South Korea caught up
and largely surpassed Japan in
semiconductors all while China's economy
was being led from the doldrums by Deng
xiaopeng they had studied Japan's
industrial policies closely and they
were applying the lessons other
countries were catching up and eating
into Japan's market share just as it had
done in Prior decades Japan's government
and Central Bank failed at Key moments
so did its companies they stopped
innovating and they expanded into areas
that were either a distraction like
insurance and movie studios or not part
of their Core Business Like nuclear
power plants they were arrogant and
dismissive about competition from Korean
and Chinese electronics companies the
biggest reason for the failure of
Japanese companies however is the
business model that allowed the kariatsu
to grow so large in the first place
close collaboration with the government
a heavy focus on traditional Industries
and a reluctance to admit foreign
companies people and ideas these
strategies couldn't confront two major
developments in the global economy the
decentralization of Supply chains and
software let's start with the first
throughout much of the 20th century
Supply chains were centralized that
rewarded vertically integrated
manufacturers who could control the
production process from research and
find financing through to manufacturing
final assembly and distribution this
helps explain the success of Industries
like car making in Detroit shipbuilding
in England and electronics Manufacturing
in Japan globalization which is the
liberalization of trade barriers and
improvements in transportation and
Communications changed all of that today
production is highly modular and Supply
chains are Global that prioritizes
flexibility and means Capital flows to
lower cost jurisdictions manufacturers
make greater use of Outsourcing and
offshore their operations as well as buy
from foreign suppliers decentralized
manufacturing undermine the competitive
advantage of Japan's keretsu which
relied on long-term relationships with
suppliers Banks and workers it's
interesting to compare Japan's continued
strength in products characterized by
internal production like cars and
cameras to its weaknesses in those that
have shifted to modular production such
as smartphones there's really no better
example than semiconductors as we
learned in my previous video about tsmc
its founder Morris Chang Bay basically
made one big bet he was going to build a
pure play Foundry a company that did
nothing but make chips tsmc helped break
apart what had been a highly centralized
industry good news for them and the
hundreds of startups that could
Outsource their manufacturing but bad
news for Japan the second part of the
transformation in manufacturing was the
rise of software you might think that
Japan would excel in software after all
they brought the world Kaizen the
practice of continuous incremental
Improvement but Japan hasn't been able
to operate on the Leading Edge of
software development many economists
actually pointed Japan's weakness in
software as the single biggest factor in
the country's competitive decline
relative to the United States one study
found that U.S firms that improved their
performance over the 1990s made the
biggest improvements in the areas where
software was most critical think about
so many of the electronics Goods that we
associate with the era of Japanese
dominance personal entertainment devices
like the Sony Walkman or the Nintendo
Game Boy cameras made by companies like
Nikon reliable efficient cars like the
Toyota Corolla these are all great great
products that Drew on Japan's
superiority and craft manufacturing but
they were all fundamentally mechanical
products they relied on Hardware not
software so as software changed our
tastes and created a new class of
products many of these mechanical goods
and the companies that made them were
left behind think about it do you own a
stand-alone radio or digital camera
today or do you just use your American
or chinese-made smartphone what about
your TV was it made in Japan or South
Korea Japan's economic collapse in the
1990s was so devastating and traumatic
that the Japanese people refer to it as
the Lost decade although today it's
probably more accurate to say lost
decades what did it look like let's
paint a picture Japan's economic growth
slowed almost to half its market share
in critical Industries like
semiconductors plummeted and it meant
the Japanese electronics companies which
had been ascended until recently started
to become Irrelevant in 2005 when Apple
built the iPod Steve Jobs needed to be
in Japan regularly because Japanese
companies produce 7 70 percent of the
parts there were some of Apple's key
suppliers but just five years later
Apple had shifted their manufacturing
strategy away from Japan and toured
China this led to the iPad using only 20
Japanese Parts remember how I said
earlier that in 1989 32 of the world's
top 50 companies by market cap were
Japanese well by 2018 there was just one
Toyota the central preoccupation of
Japanese politics since the last decade
has been to revive the dynamic culture
of economic growth that was once a
secular religion but despite the best
efforts of leaders like the late Abe
Shinzo who spent his second prime
ministership trying to stimulate the
economy the sleeping giant wouldn't wake
why because in addition to those huge
changes I mentioned there are other
factors which weigh heavily against
Japan the first is demographics Japan is
really old it sells more adult diapers
than baby diapers the baby boom
generation born in the late 1940s and
50s is retiring and there are enough
young people to replace them in 2014
Japan's population was 127 million at
current rates that's expected to shift
to 107 Million by 2040 and 97 Million by
2050. how can you be expected to be at
the Forefront of the ideas and
Technology shaping the future if you're
too old to take advantage of those
opportunities Japan's demographic
challenge is closely related to another
problem the country's reluctance to
admit new people and new ideas those
people bring the US isn't perfect but it
still boasts an unrivaled culture of
dynamism and optimism built largely on
the contributions of skilled migrants
who want to improve their lives and
contribute to the next generation of
Innovations the other is that having now
been in Decline for as long as it was on
the rise Japan has a lot of ground to
make up in order to catch countries like
the United States and China Guided by a
Visionary and vigorous government
working in tandem with the industrial
and banking sectors there was a time
when it looked like Japan and Japanese
technology companies might rule the
world that era of dominance is over
Japan today faces massive challenges
let's hope that like it once did it can
overcome them and create another
economic miracle thanks for watching